let's bring in lieutenant general keith
kellogg is a former national security
adviser to vice president mike pence and
the co-chairman of the america first
policy institute center for american
security so all the talk general this
afternoon has been this this appeal that
zolensky has made to nato to uh commit
to a no-fly zone uh over ukraine which
would basically use the the color blue
because nato is known as the blue force
and that would basically make all of
this an area i guess north of crimea
where russian planes could not fly
here's what jen stoltenberg the nato
secretary general said about it we are
not part of this conflict and we have a
responsibility to ensure it does not
escalate and spread beyond ukraine we
understand the desperation but we also
believe that if we did that a no-fly
zone we would end up with something that
could lead to a full-fledged war in
europe involving much more uh countries
and much more suffering but general you
say
that there is a way to do it how well i
think there is and it look i think we're
walking into act two of greek tragedy
and right and that act two will start
with them the russians going into the
major build-up areas primarily key city
of three million and you're going to see
streets of street fighting so you're
going to see a lot of the
councils out there civilian casualties
and i think it is when you start seeing
those visions of of those people dying
the civilians i think the world's going
to say you know i'm tired of this this
enough stop
and i think what the united states could
do is not get nato involved but they can
go to the u.n and they could say under
articles 27 and 52 wait a second there's
a way to do this have a u.n no-fly zone
not a nato no-fly zone where article 5
doesn't apply and who would enforce that
well do you well we were probably
involved in it under you uncover
but under the are both of those articles
all you need is nine of the 15 votes of
the un security council to get it moving
and according to article 5
wow that's where article 52 comes in
because article 15 is very specific
article 52 says if you're part of a
conflicted party you're part of it you
are supposed to by u.n rules absolutely
so if we could get an interlocutor like
macron to pick up the phone and call
putin and call
maybe president xi and say hey look we
want you both to abstain look putin is
not winning this fight putin is losing
this fight and he would look at ways to
say well let me get where is my off ramp
and my off ramp is with all this
economic problems i've got there may be
a way to do it and if the united nations
comes into the world body and says this
is going to be a u.n no-fly zone then we
honor what zelinski has wanted we keep
nato out of the fight now is this high
risk of course it is is it a perfect
plan no it's not no plans are perfect
but it's there's a way to do it and we
should at least explore it that is an
interesting formula let me come along to
where we are now in terms of uh of this
invasion and we go to the south because
this is the area where we have seen most
of the action now on the part of the
russians they have moved uh past her son
apparently now they're heading toward
mikalayev which inevitably follows the
the road which goes this way into right
into odessa uh i assume that the russian
plan is to surround the back part of
odessa because you see you've got rivers
over here on this side you could
basically cut the city off and then at
the same time they're moving up here to
the northeast to mariupol and then here
at enerhodar they have captured the
zaparisian nuclear power station
in terms of the strategic positioning
what does that give russia now that it
can use for the future well would oh
this would be a fight in the city
because that's the third largest city
it's going to be a major battle if they
want to go in there
and you're right about the plan do and
that is probably to cut it off and
isolate it and then i'll have it from
the c access and from the ground access
if they want to go in there on the
nuclear power plant you asked a question
a couple days ago and it was a great
question and i think people who really
didn't pick up on it what they're trying
to do is shut down the power grid this
is an attack on this evaluation civilian
populace of ukraine and you caught it
and that's they've now got both of the
major power plants
the uk uh the nuclear power plants
fortunately there's two more on the
western edge they can't get to those at
all but if you start shutting that down
there's clearly an attack on on the
humanitarian
centers
and without power it's going to start
putting more and more pressure on them i
think that's why they're doing it look i
think what they did was
absolutely way out of bounds i know in
the american military we would put big
boxes around no fire areas you don't go
into those and they've just
accelerated the problem that they have
right now in terms of the psychological
aspect of all of this general we got
news today that ukrainians ukraine
claims that one of its snipers took out
uh
i guess what is one of the leading
generals of uh the airborne assault uh
into ukraine you were airborne yourself
what what sort of morale booster is that
for the america for the ukrainian forces
i've always believed that a dead general
is always good for morale and it really
says support the troops out there it
really does i mean that proves that
they're attacking
their ukrainians are attacking the
targets correctly now
now i get if it's a backhanded
compliment to the russians that's what i
expect airborne commanders to do to be
at the front of the fight but when you
take out a senior commander like that it
builds everybody up you're saying we are
actually fighting this fight we're
winning this fight if you don't have
generals like that dying on the other
side you said are we being are we
accomplishing the mission and the reason
why that's important is the vdv their
airborne forces their primary assault
forces along with best net it's not bad
to kill those generals out there i mean
they did it right but as jack keane was
pointing out earlier today russia's got
plenty of generals
[Laughter]
ukraine's got plenty of ammunition too
well we've got some special generals
here and you're one of them general
keith kellogg thanks so much for being
with us appreciate it hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else